you said you're a sports fan were you
excited about that were you rooting for
the with the Cubs
I flipped like 10 times because I love
Cleveland I also love Chicago and the
3430 on Steve Bartman kind of soured me
on Cubs fans because it really had that
whole mr. Smith goes to Washington sort
of like you know heroes like you know
wait it's play too and you know we win
still we lose some and then you just see
what they did to that kid it's like oh
these are the same at the kid that it
tried to catch a ball with 12 other
people that for some reason didn't get
in trouble they all picked this guy cuz
it landed on him and I just looked at
him like you guys did this these are the
same pieces who vote for the Red Sox
root for the Yankees you're all the same
people so now I was like yeah I'll root
for the Indians then they went up three
games to one and all of a sudden Indian
fans started talking trash saying how
they were gonna be a dynasty or
something like that they would they were
Titletown now I was like to hell with
Cleveland I'm really like a I'm just
like a contrarian yeah I getting that
sense very much it's enjoyable you need
to be medicated you need to be out here
when Hillary loses right like I wouldn't
to be in Kentucky when Hillary loses and
everybody's skipping around that's
boring you know the whole thing is just
like about annoying people like when
people tweet it's very easy to piss off
one side the art is too tight you got to
try to get everybody so you tweet stuff
like Trump is such a dope
he's actually gonna make me vote for a
woman right and then you just sit back
[Applause]
just watching that's what I wanted what
I wanted
you've got everyone yelling at your real
out of a box well what about the cereal
for hey what about the nf I know you're
a big NFL fan you love you just like
declining ratings you think the NFL has
a problem they're starting to say
they're losing viewership now they're
people who care about football still are
still watching if they just got they got
too big they just went all papi they had
everybody dressing in pink right there's
always jets flying over support the
troops Katy Perry's doing a dance right
they just they just took it way too far
you know what I mean honey and I ain't
not into like watching like the Sunday
night game the Monday night game you're
not a football fan I just think that
they went they went too crazy with right
so it'll set a little bit a little
battle and hopefully they'll finally get
that whole pink scam out of it too you
know
isn't it like 1/2 a 1/2 a 1/2 percent
actually goes to somebody who has like a
head cold and then the rest of them go
out and buy the couch ient pink yachts I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about help me out here do you know how
they wear pink yes support breast
awareness holiday or aware oh that
there's breath I was raising money
somehow
you're not paying attention 92y black
you yeah supporting yeah supporting
breast cancer but you you see ok so you
think there's too much of that is that
what you're saying no I'm just saying
that I was on you know the internet and
I was reading that a lot of the money
goes into their pockets so I was like
all right I want to agree with that and
say that that's true and then repeated
on
f is for families season two but note
those smooth transition there's no
smooth transition I'm gonna make up a
transition you know does you're pretty
funny it's fine it starts with F F is
for family
season to edgy for a comedy show free
animated show yes
that's because we're on Netflix and they
let us basically do whatever we want
in fact the first season their network
notes were push it further which is
basically the dream if you're in a
writers room right and we did get we
just have been having a great time and
do you try to base it in reality it's
loosely based on my childhood and I had
a very volatile father you know loved
the guy to death but he definitely could
have brought the volume down a little
bit sometimes but you know who's in his
underwear a lot and I think a lot of
people can relate to that yeah I think
what if you make it a real person and
they're screaming at real kids people
get nervous so but if you drama
people don't care about animated kids so
[Applause]
you